[Music]
hello everyone I'm woman's Grandmaster
Savina for sure and we are here at the
San Luis chess club for the endgame
exclam and I'm going to continue the
theme that I started last week with the
Zook swung but we'll have some other
positions that are not technically in
the theme some of them might be familiar
so if they are we're gonna go a little
bit faster over them if not of course
we'll spend the time so let's get
started with the first position
it's a bishop endgame so as I was
telling you last time of course zoogs
vieng is typically prominent in king
opponent games but it does work in other
positions as well including middle games
but now let's see a bishop end game so
anyone familiar with this position
should be pretty famous so basically
typically in Bishop end games bishops of
the same color you always want to to
look at your opponent's weaknesses right
and in this case black has three so we
have this point in the oops that should
not happen the spawn there this one and
this one so when there are three
weaknesses it is hard for the opponent
to protect them all right the bishop can
be a six is a weakness too but you
cannot really attack it so that's the
reason why I did not mention it these
three pawns d5 f 5 and H 5 are all
possible to be attacked by both the key
well this one can be attacked by the
King but all the other ones can be
attacked by the bishop this one in a6 I
agree with you it is a weakness but
unless you find a way for your Bishop to
teleport to b7 or c8 you cannot attack
it right so we are going to focus on
these three pawns and basically in this
position if it would be black to move
black would have no more
no good move y-yes
exactly so if he moves the bishop
somewhere he's going to lose one of
these pawns if he moves the King well
the Kings are in opposition and right
now white might consider enter in C 545
if you let d5 know because I mean if you
would move you would try to go you know
maybe to c6 right okay you're right if
he goes to these things you could take
the phone okay so we are going to try
with white to get this position with
black to move how do we do that well
we're because your King cannot make any
triangle here right and if you move the
King away from d4 then well black will
also be allowed to move his King so you
need to kind of lose a move basically
with your Bishop the Kings are not going
to be moved Bishop e2 okay what should
black do here where should on which
diagonal should he move his bishop
6 or Bishop e8 right so let's just look
if he goes Bishop g6 what do you do now
f1 and what's your idea so if you go
Bishop f1 here I will go
Bishop p8 no because if I go Bishop EA
to go Bishop g2 you attack my pawn I
have to protect it and then Bishop f3
and it's over we get this position right
which you have no moves you're gonna
gonna lose upon so I'm going to go
Bishop f7 here what do you do now
Bishop h3 ok what is black doing how do
I protect this pawn I can protect it in
a 6 or g6 ok
Bishop g2 Bishop f7 Bishop f3 right and
you're winning again so then I go Bishop
e8 what do you do now so Bishop g6 is
the only move and now I do okay okay
Bishop g8 Bishop e6 Bishop f7 and you
didn't manage to get me to be my turn so
you typically want to see which of the
diagonals are the shortest if you look
here right there are three moves that
you have on this diagonal there are
three moves that you have on this
diagonal but there are only two moves
for example that you have on this
diagonal to protect your point in f5 so
if you somehow attract black on that
diagonal you're going to be able to give
him the move so if you go the first move
Bishop e2 let's go back to the starting
position if you go Bishop e2 black goes
Bishop ei8 Bishop d3 we attack this pawn
now black has two moves what are those
moves Bishop d6 d7 okay let's look at
bishop the bishop December first
what do we do now Bishop e2 he goes back
Bishop e8 Bishop c2 first because now
what do you want to do your next move is
going to be Bishop do you want to attack
that pawn if he's not paying attention
and he goes Bishop c8 you go Bishop d1
and he has no way to protect upon you
will win that one so he needs to play
Bishop e6 and now what do you do
Bishop d1 you attack the pawn you're
forcing black to protect it and now you
get Bishop f3 and black isn't Suk's monk
he has to give you one of the pawns and
then I'm assuming everyone here and the
people who are watching are going to be
able to win this with an extra pawn
right ok I hope so okay so let's go to
see the other line
if after Bishop e2 Bishop e8 Bishop d3
we go Bishop g6 with black we go on this
other diagonal g6 h7 to protect that
point it's the same thing
Bishop c2 black has to wait on the
diagonal bishop h7 bishop
well bishop do you want directly then I
go here if you go f3 I go Bishop f7 if
you go Bishop e2 I go Bishop here
bishop where
the same position so here it was
important to play Bishop III first you
attract black on this diagonal so when
you attack this pawn h5 he has to go
Bishop f7 and then you get your Bishop
to f3 you are combining the attacks on
all of these three pawns and you're
combining them on the diagonals where
black only has two moves with the bishop
and this way after Bishop D one wish of
f7 Bishop f3 we have got ours looks like
once again so I remember when I first
started this as a kid it was I was so
impressed by this because you can do
this with the bishop and for some of you
who are here for some of the other hours
that were taught by Jim residents I know
they're focusing also on you know the
knight not being able to lose a move but
with the bishop you can do that so
that's the you know cool thing about
having bishops but okay
Knights are great as well so are we go
through this position yes good so let's
go to the next position that I have and
this is a game that was played some time
ago by former world champion Alexander
Alekhine and he has white here and if we
were to evaluate this position who would
you say is better or who should be
winning
yes white of course it has an exchange
up and things seem to be going their way
but black does have some counterplay
these two points are past protected
right and the king is not really in
front of them to stop them in this
position it is black to move and tartar
cover who's playing black played f3 now
what is blacks threat and what should we
do here in this position with white
efore yes of course black wants to start
pushing the ponds so defending and then
bringing the bishop chase you look away
or push III you know try to try to get
the chance to to improve the position of
the pawns and get them towards promotion
so what should we do here with white
there's just one move that is winning
here for whites some surprisingly no
this is the only move that is winning
for white and let's see why for example
if you go King c2 it's similar to King
c4 black pushes the pawn now what do you
do
before to try to get it to win it no and
now II yeah now III
f2 is actually not not a good move why
ruge d1 and the rook stops their pawn
and then the king well if you push or
not the king will come to d3 remember if
you have a bishop and to pass pawns
you always want to push your pawns on
the same Cup I mean on the on the
opposite color now on the opposite color
than the near Bishop because if you push
them on the same color and you have them
like this
III f2 your opponent will be able to
block eight them and you have no way to
chase that piece away that's why you
want them to be on light square because
if they are blocked you have a checksum
how to change the king or look away but
if you push up to you you messed up your
pawns but here it is III the black place
and the problem is how do you stop the
pawns can you play the key for f2 what
else can you do here
can you play room D one and then f2 or
Bishop g3 depends remove my rock and if
I play King d3
II - Kim D - Bishop g3 look here
f2 loses I take the pawn with the king
right so what do you do here with black
King d7 can i play for example rook no I
can't can i play a g5
hmm
you want oh sorry okay what do we do
here with black
Misha page four and you're kind of
insuk's one you cannot push the Jeep on
if you push b3 what do I do
what is my idea with Bishop h4
can't they just to check and come back
and your king cannot approach further
the pons and Windham that's the problem
that you have can you I don't know like
okay after Bishop h4 can you play maybe
look here no f2 can take I take your
pony knee to Bishop where did you say
okay and I cannot play look at five so
that move didn't really help me very
much I can also not play rook III
because I fall into some traps and the
problem is with all this extra material
white cannot win in this position after
you know Bishop g3 Bishop h4 it's it's a
draw surprisingly all of this because
black has been able to push the pawns in
the right way on the light square so
he's using the dark square to actually
you know annoying you and not be able to
to get close to his pawns that's the
reason why TC 4 does not work the other
move that I had here is root d1 which
actually is a blunder can you find why
efore and now you want to bring your
king right King see to to stop the pawn
the pawns I'm sorry III are you sure
which one we should be for or III III it
was but I think if you play Bishop f4 f
1 yeah F 1 but then how will my king no
but if you do this I can push e 3 E 2
I don't know
yeah
but earlier in this position if you play
III immediately King D 3e - with tempo
where do I move my queen
Oh somebody forgot their Facebook okay
so okay it was not mine
e - and now what's you know what do you
play here Bishop f4 is my next movement
than F - well F - doesn't work yeah it's
probably the same it's probably the same
kind of thing so in this position rook
d5 is a super super awesome move wait in
this position excuse me rook d5 is a
super great move because now you know it
seems kind of counterintuitive to place
your hook in d5 when black is about to
push the pawns but the thing is f2 is
not really something that black wants to
do they don't want to place the pawns on
dark square if you've already seen that
right if you play f2 route comes back
you play E for what do we play QC -
let's say play Bishop f4 it's not really
helping me very much right look f1 the
King if you don't push the a pawn my
King can come to e2 and and I'm winning
I've been able to block eight these two
passed pawns which are basically giving
black the counter play so I've located
them on black which is the same color as
the Bishop and that's the reason why
we're winning because they cannot push
them for forward so after rook d5 which
is such a strong move tactic often went
on to play E for now what was the idea
why do we need the look in d5 and it was
not good to have it in d1
the idea is that when our king will come
to stop the pawns we will have those
squares free for our King so in this
position look at five and if Bishop g3
you can start pushing the pawn but wait
I had another line which doesn't appear
here
so what happens if black pushes e3 you
take the pawn then I push it too
or what did you say I'm sorry I didn't
hear and you won Queen takes takes g6
you cannot stop the pawn right so black
played King d7 g6 if instead of king D 7
I push f2 what do you do here with white
which is exciting you can go with the
Jew poem but let's imagine didn't have
that pawn then you had the opportunity
to play king c2 because no because the
King would come and block it the pawn
has been blockaded by itself on on dark
square it cannot push forward then if
you stop the e pawn then you're going to
be able to win so after King D 7 g6 King
g6 what do we do require look f8 which
one would you play look a fatal g7 which
one
g7 take the rook promote
Bishop f4 oh come on we should be able
to win this how do we win this with
white h7 you mean certainly that would
work try to get that pawn and then you
know everything I mean you have an extra
queen and those pawns are not a threat
for you so you're going to be able to
win for example check check which is how
it fold in the game took that pawn King
g3 and now we knew one f2 that's a way
to block it it what if after Queen you
wanna go King G - oh please don't play
Queen D - no you can go back we nee for
okay you should not let that pong go in
the game
Alec I played Queen g6 the King has to
go back to protect the bishop obviously
if you push the F pawn your Bishop will
be lost and then you know I can even
sacrifice my queen on your pawn I'll be
able to win with three versus two here
with your king outside King there he
took some pawn and b6 and black resigned
but the important thing in this position
which I liked and I thought it would go
well with the theme was the fact that
route d5 was the move in the position
which kind of creates this looks funk
black really from the starting position
black has no moves that would help him
after rook t5 has no moves that would
help him you know balance he's
positioned like balance his pawns like
push them the way they want to which is
before e3 something like that you don't
manage to do it your pawns will be
blockaded on dark square so they will be
on darken I'm not quite sure how it's
how it's better to say that they're
located on dark or white but you
understand what I'm saying they would be
on dark and you would be
light-square so hopefully it makes sense
of course you can analyze it by yourself
and you should knowing the classics is
very important you you learn a lot of
ideas of course there on those times
because there are no computers also you
know you can find a lot of mistakes but
that's good if you can find mistakes
because you know it means you have
dedicated time analyzed and figured out
okay this was a mistake
you know I can improve I can improve
this or yeah so some of the openings
that were older you know maybe didn't
stay until nowadays but endgames
certainly are always great material to
to learn it was here yes here it was
from the other your right from I didn't
mention that good point so yeah here it
was black that had this looks one
because you don't have a good move two
to four to win your dad f3 pawn so your
rook has to kind of stay stopped Bishop
f4 if you would play something like you
know after rook after rookie for you try
to stop that
putting the rookin III would lose the
the pawn so good so the next position is
actually ah no it's not that one yet
okay let's do this one this is a little
bit tricky and okay there are some
mistakes from both sides and it's more
more recent game what do you guys think
about this position
yes yes draw because you saw the results
somewhere no okay
why do you think this would end in a
draw yes Bishop rook versus rook should
be a draw do you guys know how to draw
that there was a class great okay it's
it's pretty you know you you always have
to be careful you saw like some people
lost it some people i won once or twice
rook and Bishop you have to be careful
about the defense and you have to
remember there's actually a Philidor
position in that as well
not the Philidor rook pawn versus root
but rook Bishop versus versus rook so
you have to be careful but in this
position yes this this should end in a
draw but it didn't if I'm not mistaken
so white went on to play King f1 what is
the idea what is he trying to do kind of
make a fortress so he's thinking you
know if I keep my King here F 1 G 2 and
my rook on the F file you'll never be
able to train the pawn and it should be
a draw right is that true can't black
have any chances to win this
how okay yeah they made it they made
some mistakes if I'm not if I remember
correctly so G for obviously taking here
does not work did you guys calculate the
king and pollen games and game and game
yes somebody can somebody tell me the
line without moving the pieces yes
okay okay Wow
okay I didn't expect that but uh how
about g4 here can you choose a truck as
you keep the opposition right and why do
you say king you're five g4 okay that's
nice you can do that
luckily for you and if I play this okay
you know it's good job yeah
the ponies on the fifth rank so it
doesn't help poor black to win great so
black has tried he didn't want to accept
a draw immediately if you look at the
Ray I mean the ratings black with a 2500
player and white is 23 50 so you know
when you play against the lower rated
player you typically want to try to push
as much as possible you don't want to
accept a draw too fast at least I would
not want but sometimes you can over push
and lose so you gotta be careful you
need to keep you know you need to play
the position not the rating of your
opponent that's that's really important
is this is something that a lot of us
don't do we see it you know we when we
teach we say that but when we play with
sometimes to make the mistake of playing
the rating so your opponent it's not the
best thing to do so black played g4 here
and now Ruka for now what is happening
after King g2
how do you do now with white and can I
make any draw some how can I save myself
here you sure
okay so white has to do something here
so they play rook a4 check try to switch
to trader F phone for the Jeep on that's
the only way that they can try to do
something here otherwise the King and
pawn endgame is lost if you move the
King somewhere else we'll still get that
endgame right who didn't play G for
white he played you for here I'm sorry
white played rukka for check because we
saw the King and pawn endgame was a draw
so with the pawn in G for the King and
pawn endgame now is winning if it's
black to move right if white make some
random move we just saw it right if you
play King G 2 we trade everything and
then King d3 and black is winning
because the pawn is on the fourth-ranked
instead of the 5th
once you come King f1 you know this you
sure don't seem so sure so basically
like you take the opposition right and
the pawn is on the 4th rank so black is
winning anyways ok so that's the reason
why in this position white said ok I
cannot wait for the King opponent game I
cannot allow it to happen I need to do
something so he gave this cheque King do
three and he took in g4 how can we try
to create some winning chances for black
rook takes F - King you one look at
three what's the idea
very nice
so rook F 3 is a very nice idea you're
threatening bishops III check King goes
to D 1 look F 1 mate is this a sucks one
position or does white have a solution a
defense rook to f4 check King D one
rookie three if you take the pawn how
what well now you're getting kind of the
Philadelphus so what should you do here
with why to try to to save yourself you
only have one move which one look after
rook g1
yes there is a way so sometimes you put
your routine f2 and you have that check
but you only do that when when actually
the opponent doesn't have a mate on the
last rank you gotta be careful when you
do it so you put there you have the rook
in f2 and then you give that check and
you cannot take it because it's cell
mate and that's how you save yourself
but now you cannot do that because your
mate so let's say a play rook rook g8
which one why don't you give a check
just to make him go back right it's more
active I mean you want some activity
with your king you give the check first
to chase the king away and then you you
play something like the rook on the
third-ranked just don't get made so
black is trying to win here he played
rocky 3 so that was kind of a Dukes
wrong position earlier by the way here
right but white had a safe only move ok
this rookie 3 what should Y do in this
position rook f1 only move ok is there
any way we can put white in zoogs van
here ok so what do we do and g1 - yeah
so it's gonna be pretty hard so black
play Bishop d4 he's giving you the move
and in this position white player cuff -
he's waiting for Bishop c3 back but he
cannot play root D - just yet he still
has a pawn on the board the fact that
the pawn is still on the board kind of
helps black because you always have
moves with the Jeep on so Bishop c3 rook
f1 I don't know why I had it with the
dubious that's a blunder of D - okay
rook f1 and now black player g5 look
after a king there
okay check check
try to wind on the other side and now
white made a mistake he gave this Roxy a
check you have to always try to give the
right checks and it's not so simple but
typically it's on the side that you give
most of the checks and you try to make
sure that as you give the checks you
have the exit with your king so if he
hides behind the bishop you can exit
this way but instead white play Roxy a
check so he didn't actually lose because
of because he was lost he lost because
he made some mistakes in d3 now what is
blacks threat pretty simple okay one and
now after check what do we do Bishop
walks in front Bishop g4 now we still
have that threat what should do I do
well he has one more move to defend
rugby b8 well what's happening here okay
one would be one Bishop e3 king b2 o ro
G 2 and now you're kind of insuk's monk
why is white and souk slang
you're threatening mate and because the
rook is badly placed you're threatening
check check and rupee one check so if
you try to escape that way that's what
happened to poor white there are a lot
of zoo compositions in drug Bischoff
versus rook in this case white had an
extra pawn but he was unable to to hold
it because he didn't realize about this
idea so if you ever play rook Bishop
versus rook don't give up try to bring
the opponent's king you know to corner
it or restrict it to the side and then
you know you'll have the ideas to to to
win like don't give up okay I think we
still have time for and now although
this is not part of what we should be
doing which is endgame exclam I wanted
to emphasize on the zoobank a little bit
really fast for this position do you
know this one okay so this is kind of
you know okay so what is the move here
after looking one what did black play h6
and I wanted to come after age six white
has no moves it's the middle of the game
but h6 basically stops everything and
what is black threat rook f3 and just
wraps the Queen and why it has no move
so that was just like a extra extra
stuff okay now let's do some studies why
to move what is happening I don't know
I mean I can tell you the results but so
what do you think let's evaluate and
look when you get the position obviously
the first instinct is to us whose turn
it is and and what is happening but when
you're playing is anyone telling you
what is happening obviously they tell
you whose turn it is cuz you already
know but nobody tells you what is
happening so you got it evaluate the
position and figure out yes okay so how
do you go for the draw do you guys know
this you know this one okay so what's
the idea what's the idea of this
position to make a draw fork
No
B to Queen yeah
King takes d5 b to Bishop e5 can I
promote no no no I'm pretty sure it's
not a draw Queen versus two bishops
especially if I can win them the idea is
I'll give you a hint of the idea the
idea is stalemate actually yeah so I'm
combining zukes vanquish stalemate today
in this position
zooks Bank
they shall be five I have to take I
don't know what's happening now B - okay
so you take on d5 if I push then you
take I promote whatever draw Bishop okay
so so let's see let's see some other
more so I've got King f5 and f6 that's
seeking f6 what's happening after this
King c4 membership here this pretty
simple right how about if I move my
bishop
King somewhere and and Bishop before
okay and last thing if I play Bishop f5
a king at five I'm sorry how is the
stalemate Bishop c6 okay and I play b2b
shall be five I promote uh-huh yeah yeah
you have to promote to a queen if you
make a look I'll give you check and take
it right well if black promotes to a
bishop be sure you do not play Bishop C
- okay because they can make these two
bishops okay
and what do you do you two bishops
versus a bishop should be a draw
Bishop c6 okay you can you can probably
play that Bishop somewhere just not see
- and you were just anywhere but see -
and when he yeah if you're playing a
blitz and you have the pre move on your
website bad luck for you because and
actually I remember I was I was playing
at some point I started playing bullet
which I don't recommend by the way
really I do not recommend bullet only
when you want to have fun and relax for
a little bit and I was so mad because I
didn't win because I didn't have this
promotion so it wastes time to actually
promote to a queen so of course I made
sure that I put my I put it so that it
always promote so a queen and then I
play the game and I I could not provide
I realize that if I promote it it would
be a stalemate so yeah I suffered there
so that was it hopefully you enjoyed
today's class we didn't go over all of
them but that's okay we'll have some
more for next time
[Music]